today we'll learn how to do three
distinct things in flutter first we'll
capture an image from the device using
the camera or photo gallery next we'll
allow the user to crop rotate or scale
the image file and lastly we'll upload
the file to a cloud storage bucket and
we'll even throw in a progress bar and a
pause resume button just because it's so
easy to do with flutter and firebase if
you're new here like and subscribe and
follow along with the full write-up on
fire ship I own let's start by taking a
closer look at what we'll build over the
next few minutes you can see down here
in the bottom bar we have two icon
buttons tapping the camera will bring up
the device camera and the image will
bring up the image gallery when the user
selects an image it will give us access
to that file object in our dart code
when the user taps the crop button it
will bring up the image crop or widget
allowing the user to manipulate the
image and that magic is made possible by
the awesome image crop rap legend and
lastly when the user taps the upload to
firebase button it will immediately
start uploading the file to a firebase
storage bucket the progress indicator
will show the percentage of bytes
transferred while the file is uploading
and the user can also control the state
of the upload by pausing or resuming
them so that's a lot of functionality
for a single YouTube video but I think
you might be pleasantly surprised at how
easy this stuff is to implement to get
started you'll need to have a flutter
app with firebase installed I'm not
going to cover the firebase setup
instructions in this video but you can
follow the official instructions or take
the full flutter course as a fire ship
Pro member now if we go ahead and jump
into the pub spec yamo file you can see
we have firebase core and storage these
are the only two firebase dependencies
that you need if your only concern is
uploading files to a cloud storage
bucket but in our case we also want the
user to interact with the native device
camera and image gallery which we can do
with image picker and then image cropper
will allow the user to then manipulate
the image after it's been selected and
these plugins do have a small amount of
platform specific configuration when it
comes to image picker you'll need to go
into your info.plist file for iOS and
add the corresponding permissions for
the photo library and camera and for
image cropper there's no config for iOS
but you do need to add an activity to
your Android manifest file and you
should always refer to the official
documentation when installing a new
plugin in flutter now moving over to our
main dart file we'll go ahead and import
these dependencies and the only other
unusual thing is that we're importing
dart IO and that gives us access to the
file class which we'll see in use here
in a couple minutes now the app or
building has two very different concerns
with one being the image capture from
the device and the other being the file
upload to a remote storage
and we can easily separate these
concerns and flutterby creating two
different stateful widgets the first one
that we'll build is called image capture
and it's responsibility is to capture an
image from the gallery or camera and
then allow the user to crop and resize
it so the only piece of state on the
switch --it is the actual file itself
and the image file state will change
when the user selects an image or when
they crop an image the first method will
define as pic image which will either
allow the user to select an image from
the image gallery or capture a new image
with the camera the image picker plug-in
makes this dead simple all we do is
write a single line of code and pass at
the source which will tell it whether or
not to use the camera or the gallery and
the result of this future will be the
image file which we can set as the state
on this widget and that's all it takes
to capture an image from the native
device now the other way the image files
State might change is if the user crops
an image using the image crop or plugin
and using this plug-in is just as easy
we simply pass in the source path of the
existing image and it will take that
existing image and create a newly
cropped or modified image and you also
have a bunch of optional properties that
you can pass to the plug-in as well to
customize its behavior if the user
confirms the modification it will result
in a new image file which we can then
set as the image file state but if the
user cancels the modifications the value
will be null in which case we can use
darts nola where double question mark
operator to return the existing image
file now at this point you might be
wondering how we're getting so much
amazing functionality with only a few
lines of code
the magic is made possible by the image
copper plug-in which itself is a wrapper
for native libraries like you crop and
tío crop view controller on iOS now that
we have the logic in place to capture
and crop an image let's move on to the
UI we have a couple of buttons down here
at the bottom which allow the user to
either capture from the camera or from
the gallery and then once an image is
selected they can either crop it or
clear it by simply setting the image
file to null we can implement the
buttons down at the bottom by setting up
a scaffold and then defining a bottom
navigation bar as a bottom app bar and
we'll create a row with a couple of icon
buttons in it and each icon button will
call the same pick image method just
with a different argument for the source
which can either be the camera or the
gallery from there we'll move on to the
body of the scaffold which we'll define
as a ListView and then it will have
children if the image file does not
equal null
if we have an image file then we'll go
ahead and show it in the UI with the
image widget and then we'll display a
row with some buttons that allow the
user to crop that image or to clear it
from the UI and that code can be
implemented by simply attaching the
methods that we defined earlier as the
unpressed event handlers for these
buttons now the last widget that we'll
add here is called uploader which is a
custom widget that will define next and
we'll pass the image file down to it as
an input property the responsibility of
the uploader is to take the raw file and
then create a firebase storage upload
task one of the benefits of having this
in its own widget is that you could
potentially a loop over it to create
multiple upload tasks at once which
would allow you to upload multiple files
concurrently we can pass the file object
from the parent to the child by setting
it as a property here and then adding it
to the constructor from there we'll go
down to the state and will instantiate
firebase storage you can think of this
as a service that allows you to interact
with a cloud storage bucket to both
upload and download files you just need
to pass at a storage bucket argument
with the bucket URI which you can find
on the firebase console and what we're
here in the console I should also point
out that you should have security rules
disabled for the storage bucket just so
we can freely upload files for this demo
now back in our code we'll set a
property for the storage upload task
this is the single most important part
of the feature because it provides the
current state of the upload as well as
the event stream that we can listen to
to update the UI when you instantiate a
storage upload task it will immediately
start uploading that file to storage so
we'll go ahead and create a start upload
method that allows the user to click a
button to start the upload lazily in
addition to the file you also need to
have a path to upload that file to a
storage bucket is no different than the
file system on your computer and that
means only one file can exist at a given
path at a time many apps will generate a
unique ID for each individual upload or
a quick and dirty way to do it is just
to use date/time now so now that we have
the file path string and the raw file
object we can make a reference to the
storage bucket then call child with the
file path and then call put file with
the file object and that will return us
with a firebase storage upload task and
that's actually all it takes to upload a
file to storage but you'll very likely
want to give the user a progress
indicator and maybe the option to pause
or cancel the upload as well in the
build method we'll go ahead and start
with a conditional and if the
the upload task is null then we'll
display a button that allows the user to
start the upload so tapping this button
will create an instance of an upload
task which will immediately start
transmitting that file to your firebase
storage bucket the upload task object
also exposes a stream of storage tasks
events which we can pass to a stream
builder to update the progress bar so
we'll use a storage task event as the
generic type to the stream builder and
we'll set the stream property as the
upload task events the storage task
event object contains useful information
like the number of bytes transferred and
the total bytes in the file so you can
calculate the total progress of the
upload and you can expect the stream to
emit a new event every couple hundred
milliseconds or so now when it comes to
a progress bar we'll be looking for a
number that ranges from zero to one and
we can obtain the information to make
that calculation from the event
it contains the number of bytes
transferred to storage thus far along
with a bunch of other metadata that you
might find useful in our case here we
can get the progress percent by dividing
the total by count by the bytes
transferred now one of the really cool
things about firebase is that it makes
it easy for the user to pause cancel and
resume and upload and we can control
which parts of the UI to show based on
the state of the upload task that means
you can set up some conditional logic
and then use the different states like
is canceled as complete is in progress
etc in addition to the state the upload
tasks also contains methods for the user
to manually control the upload for
example if the upload task is paused
then we'll go ahead and create a button
that allows them to resume it and then
we can do the exact opposite if the
upload task is in progress
then we'll provide a button to pause it
and last but not least we'll want to
show the user some kind of progress
indicator an easy way to do this is with
the built in linear progress indicator
and we can use the progress percent that
we figured out earlier as its value and
for an added touch we'll go ahead and
display the progress percent as a string
as well and that's all it takes to build
a full stack file upload feature with
flutter I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and if you
want to learn more about flutter and
firebase consider enrolling in the full
flutter course or becoming a pro member
at fire ship i/o thanks for watching and
I will talk to you soon
[Music]